today we're talking about an
unbelievably stupid story of Charity
that really shows the brain rot of
crypto Bros this man's quest to Simply
donate money is going to lead him to
space but before it does I have to say
normally I am against scrutinizing
charity I think all charity you know
however you give wherever you give
however much you give it's great but
occasionally the motivations are so
gross the methods so outrageous that
it's worth making an exception and
that's what we're doing today today
we're talking about this man Eric finman
and we're talking about his quest to
save a school in Africa with
cryptocurrency but to understand the
full lore we have to start with who Eric
is actually I'll let him introduce who
he is I just want to start by saying I
love being me wait wait Eric no no it we
want to know who you are I love being
myself it's a pretty sweet deal no no
not who do you love who are you yeah I I
really love being myself it's such a joy
no Eric tell me what you do hi I'm Eric
fine I'm the world's youngest Bitcoin
millionaire I made it in Silicon Valley
and I've accomplished a lot in my life
already but now I'm leaving Big Tech to
fight for free speech okay those are two
clips of Eric from like seven years ago
and then from just a year ago and as you
can see he hasn't changed that much in
that time he still loves himself quite a
bit but in 2021 he made waves launching
the freedom phone which is the ad you
just saw and which got a ton of media
attention but it was pretty much a
commercial flop after the freedom phones
core promise of privacy failed
inspection and the chip set inside of it
this isn't the product of someone who
actually cares about privacy it's the
product of someone who's trying to take
advantage of people who aren't as tech
savvy so that was my first introduction
to Eric he's clearly a guy who knows how
to get media attention and Market
himself self but he kind of lacks that
follow through now recently I saw him
again on Fox News business and this time
he was talking about another company
he's part of which also kind of sounded
sketchy it's a Tick-Tock competitor
called lamotif which in of itself is
fine but Eric claimed in this video that
it has hundreds of millions of users on
this app and frankly I had never heard
of it you know I mean we have hundreds
of millions of users so I mean we have
an amazing you know user growth now look
the fact I hadn't heard of this app is
no big deal but I went to my phone
because I wanted to know more I
downloaded this app expecting hundreds
of millions of users instead everything
I was seeing was like family member
levels of Engagement like three to five
likes per post you know your mom grandma
and dad there was it's a ghost town
hardly anyone is on this app so again
this is my second red flag once again he
kind of over promises under delivers but
then comes the motherload of all stories
Eric starts talking talking about all
his achievements and one of them is when
he talks about a project he worked on in
Ghana to donate money let me ask you
about that project I saw you uh done
some work in Ghana uh and it really you
just did something that's really
historic I think this is important
because one thing I love about the
d-finance revolution is that it's going
to help people who would never really
people in Industries and countries that
would never really have a chance in a
traditional global banking system
yeah absolutely I mean basically we did
a a crypto version of starlink so it
starts off pretty normal he's on
national television and he's talking
about how he donated uh money you know
this is what people talk about when they
talk about cryptocurrency banking the
unbanked you know saving Africa but then
as he gave details I realized literally
none of this is necessary
um I launched a satellite a few years
ago and we put a crypto wallet on there
I believe it's the only satellite with
the crypto wallet and we were able to
beam down to a uniseco and all girls
unicef's girl school in Ghana
um with the help of the of a member of
the gone in government at the ground we
were able to ship them an antenna they
built it as a school project
um it was amazing okay wait just a
second you're telling me you launched a
satellite put a crypto wall on that
satellite and built an antenna to
receive that you had to involve the
government all to send money isn't there
a better way okay if you're already
going to be shipping an antenna couldn't
you have shipped cash and the punch line
is like maybe if it was like millions of
dollars it would make sense like oh you
can't just ship millions of dollars it
was a thousand dollars he donated a
thousand dollars to this school in Ghana
um and not just any a thousand dollars
he donated a thousand dollars worth of a
random crypto coin called metal and then
literally with no internet they were
able to beam down cryptocurrency right
down to them by the way I like it how he
passes it off as some big achievement of
like hey we sent the money even though
they didn't have internet but that's not
even true they did have internet because
you built them an antenna you could have
sent them the money that you spent on
antennas satellites and talking to the
Ghana government you could have sent it
to them but why do it that way when you
can build and send a satellite to space
we were able to ship them an antenna
they built it as a school project I I
like how he says like yeah they just set
up this antenna it's like a fun school
project like was it I don't volunteer my
free time as a Dish network technician
but maybe maybe that's just me maybe I
don't know what the the kids are doing
in school these days but by the way this
isn't even the wildest part because
already way too many steps right but
remember that Eric paid them in a
cryptocurrency which is not used by
locals at all or really anyone so guess
what happens next I'm a friend's company
mine yellow card he runs the largest
crypto Exchange in Africa yellow card
and he was able to on the ground you
know exchange the money for local
vendors
okay what have we done here after
everything all of it the satellite the
antenna the the government you've
literally had to send a guy with cash
you've had to do the thing you were
trying to avoid the doing the entire
time you're just send them cash to
exchange the cryptocurrency what is the
achievement here you're just sending the
cash with like 12 extra steps but even
worse he tries to make it seem like this
is the wonders of crypto and space it
was one of the most amazing things I've
ever seen they're able to fix their roof
they didn't even have lunch tables they
were eating their food on the ground in
the dirt and they're able to get wood
for lunch tables I mean this is this is
the amazing economy of space no Eric
this isn't the amazing economy of space
this is the fake philanthropist grift
we've seen it thousands of times before
you just give small amounts of cash to
poor countries but when you do you make
sure you bring a camera and you make a
media tour out of it while you're at it
as I said wouldn't say anything because
you know charity is mostly a net benefit
no matter the reason but this story was
just so wild the lengths they went to to
make this seem revolutionary was so
ludicrous that I had to make an
exception this is the amazing economy of
space